presenter: Thank you all for coming. Just
wanted to introduce Jeff a bit. He is a professor
of history at the University of California
Irvine. He is a specialist in Chinese history
and has written several previous titles on
the topic including "Global Shanghai", "China's
Brave New World and 20th-Century China". His
latest title "China in the 21st Century" has
been described as a guide through the thickets
of China's history and the turbo driven landscape
of its current affairs. Please join me in
welcoming Jeff Wasserstrom to Google.
[applause]
Jeff: Thanks a lot for having me. Thanks for
coming out. It's very fitting I think to speak
here because it's the center of the first
big news story that hit after I sent my drafts
off for this book. So um, there'll be something
on Google in China in the second edition if
I'm lucky enough to have one. We always say
you shouldn't judge a book by its cover, but
I'm so happy with the cover that I don't mind
if people judge it a little by this. And also
it's a striking cover that has meant something
different to me as I've been giving talks
about the book around. The basic meaning of
the cover, the top picture pulls you into
thinking about China as having changed in
many ways, that many things are going on there
that would have been unimaginable in Mao's
time, that you just don't associate with places
that are under Communist Party rule. Whereas
the bottom picture encourages you to think
about things that have been continuities,
though not complete continuities from Mao's
time because after all they are wearing western
suits rather than what we think of as the
Mao suits.
But one of the things that came out when I
gave a book talk in Irvine, and one of my
colleagues who had grown up in China said,
but you're not talking about what the men
at the top and the men at the bottom have
in common. So as the first audience participation
part of this talk, can anyone tell me what
these guys and these guys have in common?
Besides the fact that they're wearing black
and red, well their wearing western style
clothes, those are two things, but there's
something about them else that they have in
common. Nobody, almost nobody gets this right,
so don't be afraid. Yeah.
They're urban. That's a good point, yeah that
in one of the, and that I think is something
that for a long time the covers of books about
China would show you the countryside, so that's
a good thing; it reflects the fact that one
of the big stories about China is how rapidly
its urbanizing. That's a good answer. There's
a later question I'll give you where there's
a right answer and a wrong answer, this one
doesn't have it. But the answer that I, that
made, took me by surprise and then of course
I thought, of course. All of them have dyed
hair. [Laughter] The Communist Party is trying
to convince people that it's changing, and
it is changing, but it's trying to convince
them that it's got a youthification thing
going on. But the youthification often means
that a 70 year olds leadership set is giving
way to a 65 year old one. So they're actually
required to dye their hair black, or at least
that's the expectation.
The book has questions and answers, a lot
of commonly asked questions that are then
answered in various ways, often trying to
flip expectations or tell you surprising things.
In a talk about the book I can't tell you
everything you need to know but that's why
I pick out five things that everyone needs
to know. A couple of which I thought would
be particularly relevant for this setting.
Some of which I've been talking about in many
places. The first thing, and some of these
are self explanatory, some will need explanation
as I go along. China is incredibly diverse;
that's number one. When you think about China,
think about brave new world as much as you
think about 1984, even though 1984 is talked
about more often in China. And China is more
often described as Orwellian than Huxleyan,
but I think there's this as much at least
to be said for the brave new world vision.
This I probably don't need to really explain
the importance at this particular setting
but the role of the Internet in China is complicated.
The fourth, modernization is not the issue
it was. The fifth, the U.S. and the PRC are
alike in some ways. And that's important I
think because there's a tendency in the U.S.
and in China to treat our two countries as
opposites, as totally unlike. So I'm not saying
they're exactly the same, but I'm saying their
more alike than either side often realizes.
So that's the last time I'm gonna read text.
Maybe the, one of the last times I'll read
text that's on a PowerPoint. So the first
thing is that China is very incredibly diverse
and I think often the media, and by that I
don't mean what all Journalists write from
China, there's some wonderful journalists
working in China. But if you just have a sort
of passing interest in China and you're just
getting news about it from sound bites you
could easily come away with an idea that China
is an essentially homogenous place or largely
homogenous place. What I try to say in the
book is that while it may be more homogenous
in some specific ways than other places for
example, unlike the United States there aren't
a lot of people who trace their descent back
to totally different parts of the world; unlike
Indonesia there isn't quite the linguistic
variety there, it may not have as much religious
variety as India. It may be less heterogeneous
in some ways than those places, but that's
a far cry from saying it's largely homogenous.
It's in fact a very diverse place. And even
some of the things that are thought of as
representing the largely homogeneousness of
it when you push on it, start to collapse.
For example it is commonly said that 90% of
Chinese belong to one ethnic group; the Han
Chinese. And that their 55, 50 some odd other
ethnic minorities, but they only comprise
10% of the population. But if you push harder
on that and you look at the 90% Han figure,
you actually find that there are differences
among the Han that in another setting we would
describe as ethnic differences. The way in
which urban Chinese often talk about people
from the countryside, who like them are Han,
involves all the stereotyping and notions
of being of a lesser quality, is a term that
is sometimes use, that we would think, that
we would associate with ethnic or racial prejudice.
There's also a group called the Hakka which
literally means guest people, which are Han
Chinese who moved from northern China to Southern
China quite a long time ago and are scattered
out, they speak a completely different dialect
than the people living right near them. Ah,
in the 19th century when a lot of Han Chinese
women bound their feet, or at least in some
settings a lot did; the Hakka women never
bound their feet. So they had this kind of
cultural difference that in another setting
might be thought of as ethnic. There were
feuds sometimes, violence between Hakka and
non-Hakka living near each other. In another
setting that would be thought of as inter-ethnic
violence, so that's just the kind of diversity
within there. There's also religious diversity,
diversity based on region and locale. Local
identities become very important in China.
Gender, how people are experienced changes
in China. It's very different when people
ask me how Chinese feel about 'X'. These are
the kinds of things I break down. You know,
do you mean male Chinese or female? Do you
mean living near the sea coast where the cities
have been booming, or in the more hinterland
areas where the cities are hoping to boom
soon? Do you mean, what are you talking about?
But often what I come down to most, and this
is one section that I'll read a short passage
about, is age differences that I think I really
want to know how old are these Chinese that
you want me to say what's their attitude toward
America or something like that. And these
are just some images that go along with this
talk. So one of the questions that I ask in
the book and then answer is how important
are age divides in China? Generation gaps
are present in every part of the world, but
the speed with which China has changed in
the past several decades makes the one in
the PRC a chasm of unusual size. Here are
some basic facts worth noting. In 2007 more
than 40% of the citizen of PRC were under
30 years old. More than 20% were 15 or younger.
Meaning that for close to half the people
alive in China today, Mao has always been
dead. And for roughly a quarter of them the
Berlin Wall has always been rubble.
Switching from political to social issues
more than half of all Chinese were never alive
in a China that did not have a large divide
separating those who have benefitted most
from the reforms and those that have been
left behind by them. While those between 30
and 65 have a memory of more egalitarian times
that have disappeared. And those older than
that may have a, may see the current disparities
between the haves and have not's as a return
to a socially divided, economically divided
landscape that they knew in their youth that
then had disappeared and has now come back.
In cultural terms, most middle aged urban
parents are people who until they were in
their 30's never made a private phone call
or rode in a car. For the main phones were
still shared neighborhood ones and the main
urban vehicle; still bicycles and buses, as
recently as the mid 1980's which was the first
time I lived in China. And yet these people
have children who have always had mobile phones
and think nothing of hailing cabs, at least
those living in cities. This generation gap
influences an enormous number of things, from
attitudes toward the pace of modern life,
this can seem unsettling to some and bracing
to others; to views of China's place in the
world. And it affects phenomena that are presented,
often in the sound bite driven commentary,
and even in Chinese media as well, as transcending
generations. Consider for example the supposedly
timeless Chinese attachment to quote unquote
Confucian values; such as social harmony.
The oldest residents of the PRC can remember
a time when China was governed by a
non-communist regime, that of Chiang Kai-Shek
that venerated Confucius and made much of
the need to follow his moral dictates. For
Chinese born between the mid to late 1940's
and early 1960's by contrast, the current
celebration of Confucius and his ideas may
seem a bit odd, since they may remember mass
campaigns to criticize all vestiges of Confucianthought.
But for Chinese born recently who are unfamiliar
with this history, it is often ignored or
glossed over in school books and their parents
sometimes prefer not to talk about it. There's
nothing remarkable at all about President
Hu Jintao's claim that communism and Confucianism
are compatible rather than opposite ideas.
So these are some images that would seem ordinary
to some Chinese of a certain age and extraordinary
for others, things people they thought they
would never see, things that they've simply
always seen. These are fashion magazines and
modern lifestyle magazines that in Mao's day
would be considered a kind of banned literature
because they promoted bourgeois materialist
values. But now Chinese who are in their 20's
have just grown up always seeing style and
fashion magazines and don't think of it as
something that at any point would be viewed
as dangerous. And so forth.
All right. This is the Orwell vs. Huxley side
of things that I treated in my last book,
my book before last, "China's Brave New World
and Other Tales for Global Times". But I revisit
in this one in part, in part because I got
something wrong, or I didn't go far enough
in one part of it and so I get to correct
this with a new book. Um, the basic idea is
that if you think about these two books that
are often taught together or talked about
together as providing two different dystopian
views of the future, is that there are two
different views of authoritarian rule. Ah,
Huxley's, in Orwell's' view which has become
the most famous or most talked about in the
United States, certainly the one talked about
most to China, in regard to China, is a Big
Brother state where the government is watching
you, where the people are kept in line through
fear, and where the government forces you
to believe whatever it says, so they can force
you to believe that 2+2=5. It's a hard form
of authoritarianism that governs by fear.
In Huxley's "Brave New World" which was written
earlier, that actually Huxley was a teacher
of Orwell's' at Eden which is an interesting
little side fact. Um in Huxley's "Brave New
World", people are kept in line in a different
way, by the government playing to their pleasures
and their desires. So in Huxley's vision of
the future, people are kept docile through
Soma, this bliss inducing drug that's readily
available, through the feelies which are these
sort of high level immersive pornographic
forms of entertainment. So there's sort of
this way in which people don't rise up because
their blissed out and kept very busy and also
divided from one other based on lifestyles.
Whereas in the 1984 world, everybody's in
the same boat but they don't rise up because
of fear, what will happen to them. So I think
these are useful to think about these two
visions of the future. And Orwell and Huxley
when they were alive argued about which of
them they thought were the better prediction.
So with China, it's often thought of in Orwellian
terms. And when Huxley was talking, when he
was criticized in 1984, he said I don't think
the style of boot on the face rule that you
describe is really what the dictators of the
future will use. So in China there clearly
are moments and places in which the boot on
the face is exactly um, the way that control
is exercised. But I think a lot of control
or what keeps people from taking to the streets,
and it's not just in China, but throughout
the 21st Century, a lot of what's going on
is much more what Huxley was describing; a
society of the spectacle and of hedonism in
which people are too busy in various ways
to take political action and are kind of dulled
or satisfied, so the manipulation of pleasure
rather than fear can often keep people. One
of the things to think about with Huxley vs.
Orwell, is that Orwell encourages you to think
about who's watching you, and Huxley encourages
you to think about what you're watching and
what keeps you busy, and if you think about
the internet story, we can get back to that
as well. There's a side of censorship and
control by the Government, there's also a
side of the Internet in China, as the Internet
in other places, if you go to an Internet
Cafe in China, you don't find a lot of um,
young people trying to get around the great
firewall and read off limit sites. There may
be some, but you find a lot of people playing
first person shooter games, which could arguably
be one of the forms of Soma of the present
day. Now in, in my book, what I talked about
in the earlier book, I talked about China
going through 1984 periods and Brave New World
periods, which in Chinese someone is talking
about tightening and loosening of political
controls, so I said 1989, when there was a
massacre that put an end to protests in Beijing,
and scores of other cities, and then the government
came out and said there was no massacre. There
was just, there were just rioters that were
quelled by very restrained kinds of troups
and you'd better believe this. That was an
Orwellian moment, the government were saying,
with its big lie 2+2=5 and you better believe
it. Fairly soon after that there was this
loosening up of political controls and I think
there was more of a Brave New World moment.
And there was a lot of focus on consumerism,
what was keeping people from going back on
the street maybe partly fear, but partly that
they were busy indulging in new pleasures.
So I talked about this temporal side of this,
these two paradigms, but what I didn't talk
about is that there's also this geographical
side, and I wanted to read a brief part on
that.
So there's an ebbing and flowing of hard and
soft forms of authoritarianism over time in
China, but there's also a geographical dimension.
In areas with significantly large and periodically
restive non-Han populations such as Xinjiang
and Tibet, the modes of control tend to remain
much more 1984, even when the country as a
whole is in a Brave New World mode. Conversely
in booming East Coast cities such as Shanghai
with their cultures of distraction, epitomize
by public spaces dominated by massive video
screens and their glittering department stores,
Huxley tends to be a better guide. It's no
surprise these pictures were taken by me in
Shanghai. And so far while Brave New World
and 1984 have some relevance in a place like
Shanghai though it's more Brave New World,
in the former colonies of Hong Kong and Macau,
they have never, since becoming part of the
PRC in 1997, been subjected fully to 1984
like suppression. And that's another thing
is that to think about the degree of regional
variation and of course that's something I
don't need to say here, because with the internet
what goes on in Hong Kong is totally different
from what goes on in the mainland. But publishing
is very different, there'll be no problem
at all for this book to be sold in the bookstores
in Hong Kong, where lots of things that are
banned in the rest of the Mainland are sold,
there'd be different issues if it gets through
into the Mainland. The internet being complicated,
this is something I'd like to get any questions
from you, but Um, one of the complications
what I would say is one of the things that's
always important to remind ourselves is that
we think abut in many parts of the world there's
a digital divide, that's is a common term
for either people who go online or people
who don't go online. With China it's crucial
to think of multiple digital divides that
separate out people geographic area, you're
going online in Hong Kong, or the Mainland.
But beyond that are you going online and using
VPN servers that allow you to surf the web
by fooling your computer into thinking it's
going on from someplace else. In which case,
the fact that, what's happened with Google
is much, much less relevant than if you aren't
using a VPN server. If you used a VPN server
you could still be going on, on Google and
searching through the American version or
whatever. So there's a divide between people
who go online, people who don't go online,
people who go online and don't go around the
firewalls, people who go online and are somewhat
creative going around and trying to get to
sites that are off limits, people who simply
go on always using a VPN that is allowing
them to use the Net much more like the way
people in the United States are using the
Net than the people down the street might
be using the Net who don't have the technological
savvy or the interest to do that. Another
thing is the term that has taken off for talking
about control for the Chinese Internet is
the Great Firewall which I think is a clever
term. It invokes a famous symbol of China.
It encourages us to think, its lead to some
clever new language by Chinese bloggers who
talk about climbing the Great Firewall. It's
talked about once upon a time Reagan said
Gorbachev tear down that wall and now that
there should be America say tear down that
Great Firewall, you know, so there's a lot
of word play and interesting things with that.
But I think it encouraged us to view China
too exotically if we don't interrogate it.
And a term I like is what Jeremy Goldkorn
who's one of the most astute analysts of the
Chinese internet and runs a great website
in Beijing called danwei.org. He refers to
the Net Nanny. He refers to the Chinese state
as not so much, don't think of it as trying
to wall off access of information, think of
it as trying to steer users of the Chinese
Internet toward the healthy sites and away
from the unhealthy ones, much like a nanny
would. And think of China as doing things
that aren't uniquely Chinese but have a lot
in common with the Internet in other settings
where certain things that are deemed dangerous
or not fit for children or others might be
kept off limits. I mean there are limits on
pornography in many places, there are limits
on certain kinds of speech in smaller areas,
and there are places where there's limits
on a lot that goes on in the Internet, places
like Iran obviously but also places like Saudi
Arabia and Singapore where we can think about
the nanny as being a useful way to proceed.
So anyway, we can return to the Internet in
question when there are questions but I want
to get through to the two more things, that
are worth paying attention to, and there will
be a free book give away trivia question,
this time with a correct answer. That I will
use, and probably my last time I'll get to
use this. I've been using to audiences, but
once this up on YouTube I think that's shot.
I'll have to come up with a new one.
Alright, the big China question in 1978, in
China, and I think also very much around the
world was, will China be able to modernize?
After the destruction of the great leap forward
that lead to a massive famine. After the chaos
of the Cultural Revolution. Deng Xiaoping
was in charge, and he was saying his watch
word was the four modernizations. A lot of
the outside world thought finally there was
a leader of the Chinese Communist Party that
we can deal with, that seems pragmatic. So
the question was would China be able to go
from being a fairly poor country, to being
a developed country? Now though, I think the
big question outside in the world, but also
to some extent in China is how will China's
ability to have modernized and to be on the
road toward further modernization affect its
citizens and the world? It's not will China
go from being a poor country to a less poor
country which was what I think was expected
then. But as the titles of the competition,
"When China Rules the World" and books like,
that are saying. Look at what a future will
look like with a fully modern China, and often
playing to the fears of the possibilities
of that. I try to argue for a less obvious
argument to it, though I think it's what's
most interesting to me about it, is simply
that those questions are even being asked.
Nobody was saying in the late 1970's, what
will we deal with a China, or very few people,
what will we deal with a China that is hyper
modern. The question was will China be able
to feed itself, not will it become a colonial
power.
So what is interesting to me is that there
was a lot of rooting for Deng Xiaoping in
the west to succeed in this modernization.
The view of Deng Xiaoping changed, when he
was a backer of the massacre of 1989, but
from the late 1970s to the late 1980s he was
quite celebrated. Time magazine made him man
of the year twice, which they rarely do. And
he was calling these four modernizations,
agriculture, industry, science and defense.
There were protests against Deng Xiaoping.
The earliest was the democracy wall movement
of the late 1970s, which initially Deng Xiaoping
thought this was a healthy expression of differences
of opinion. Then when the people started talking
about Deng being a new dictator, he cracked
down on it. But what interests me about it
here is one of the most famous wall posters
that's well known, Wei Jingsheng who's now
one of the most famous dissidents in exile
from China, was a political prisoner and then
left. He called for a fifth modernization.
He said that China needed those four modernizations
that Deng was talking about, but it also needed
a fifth, Democracy. Now that part's well known,
but what's sometimes forgotten, is that why
he said, the argument he made for why China
needed democracy. He said because without
it, the modernization drive and economic growth
will confront insurmountable obstacles. So
he wasn't just saying a democracy an abstract
good. He's saying that without that China
will not be able to have the economic growth
it needs. And now our conundrum is China has
had this enormous economic growth without
having democracy. So it's a different setting
than saying that China needs democracy to
become modern.
Ok and here is the question where you get
the free book. I know that many of you have
it, but I'll send you another copy to give
away to a friend if you answer it right. This
is what a famous American said in 1979 when
Deng Xiaoping came to America and he was speaking
to him. "Mr. Vice-Premier, it is with great
joy that we welcome you to our country, and
it is with true love that we extend our very
best wishes to you and your people, on your
new long march toward modernization in this
century." Anybody want to guess, and I don't
know if we can get people from the places
being video-conferenced. What famous American
in the late 1970's would say that?
male #1: Jimmy Carter
Jeff: Jimmy Carter. I get that answer a lot,
it's a really good answer, but it's not right.
female #1: Nixon.
Jeff: Nixon. Another popular one, but also
wrong.
female #2: Reagan.
Jeff: Reagan. Reagan. Really good answers
that again are wrong.
[pause]
Do you want a hint? Ok, one state he is associated
with is West Virginia.
male #2: Bird.
Jeff: Bird. Good, good, good again, but not
right. Do you needanother hint? There is another
state he is associated with. Colorado. Famous
American. Not necessarily a politician. West
Virginia and Colorado. Ok, I get to keep the
book.
male #3: John Denver.
Jeff: John Denver. Give that man a book. Hey,
way to go. John Denver, who performed for
Dan Xiaoping when he came on a visit, and
anybody who lived in China in the 1980s as
a westerner who would have a better chance
of getting that right because John Denver
was some of the only music we heard when popular
music was played. John Denver and the Carpenters
came through. That just shows you how wide
spread the rooting for Deng Xiaoping was,
and now you flash forward to the 21st century.
Instead of the question of what will it take
for China to modernize, and there parts of
China of course which haven't experienced
this kind of development or modernization,
but we are now in a period where we can imagine
a fully modernized China, in this kind of
visions of infrastructure. Shanghai has more
skyscrapers than New York. Not just New York,
but the entire West Coast of the United States.
More skyscrapers. It has the fastest train
on earth, and its landscape is being used.
Shanghai, it's not just that people go there
like Merchant Ivory did to film a period epic.
Michael Winterbottom went there to film "Code
46", a cloning story set in the future, in
which he wanted to build special sets. He
thought it would cost too much money. He also
thought that the future would look more like
the present, than when you create it from
scratch. So he looked around the world for
places he could shoot, that would fool the
audience into thinking, that can't possibly
exist now. So he shot in Pudong, East Shanghai,
and Dubai. And then rolled them together and
that worked.
So China's now having engineering feats that
have impressed the world. They got a space
program; this is a very different kind of
country than the one that was asking about
the modernization. I think this is reflected
in protests. As I said the Democracy Wall
protest were saying we need a change in leadership
in order to become modern, which is what we
desire. Now a lot of times the protests have
some edge to them of the way modernity is
coming to us is effecting our lives in negative
as well as positives ways, or we should have
a say in how we are brought into the modern
world. So even things that people desire,
they want some control over, and this is something
we know from the United States and other places.
2008 was a year that really changed the vision
of China from being thought of as a backward,
to being thought of as a modern country, with
the technological displays in the stadiums
in Beijing wowing the world. The first protests
of that year, took place in Shanghai, or one
of the first protests. And it was against
the extension of the magnetic levitation train
line, this super-fast train, through a neighborhood
in Shanghai, which the local residents, who
are largely people who admired or liked the
fact that Shanghai had become this modern
city again, said we don't want it running
through our neighborhood. It's going to bring
down our housing prices, we're worried about
noise pollution, were worried about radiation
effects that would harm our children. It was
described as one of the first not in my backyard
or NIMBY protests in China. So the people
who were protesting were largely middleclass
people, or new middleclass. They organized
via cell phone and instant messaging. These
were not people who were against China modernizing,
but they wanted more control of how exactly
it was modernized. They thought that with
this type of thing we should have some say,
whether the government listens to us more.
And they actually succeeded, at least for
a time, in stopping the extension of the train
line. The year before there had been similar
kinds of protests in the city of Xiamen complaining
of a chemical plant being brought nearby.
And this is the bigger protests of 2008 were
in Tibet. There were big protests, and this
were often interpreted in the U.S. media as
being all about religious freedom. And to
some extent, of course that's part of it.
But there were also about economic grievances,
and they were also about a complaint about
having a particular version of modernization
shoved down people's throat. Which people
around the world never like to have happen.
So in Beijing, what is said about Tibet is
often that Tibetans should be grateful, because
we've brought them modern schools and modern
railways and we're linking them to the world.
What some Tibetans say, it's not that we're
against those things, but we only want those
things in a process that is benefiting us
as well as other groups that are living locally.
And we should have some say in how exactly
these things are playing out. We want a more
responsive government. So the protests in
Shanghai, the protests were radically different,
they were very different stories, but there
was a connecting thread I think, in this kind
of concern with the impact on lives of a form
of development that didn't have input from
the people being most affected. And so these
are shots of the anti-maglev protests, most
of the photographs I took. These were pulled
from the websites.
The final point, and I'll be moving to wrapping
up, is China and the U.S. have things in common,
and one of the things that I talk about in
the book in trying to bring this point home,
is talking about things that we have in common
today, which are often misunderstood. One
of the things, to the rest of the world, the
U.S. and China stand out in a special category
as the two countries. We might argue with
each other. We might say that China is the
biggest producer of greenhouse gases. They
should do something about that. And China
may respond; you are still the biggest per
capita user of greenhouse gases. You should
do something about it first. To a lot of the
rest of the world, we're the two countries
that are going to have to figure out some
way to rein in our enviromental to do something
about the environment. Together along with
some other big countries. So first of all
with a lot of issues, what we have in common
seems more striking than what sets us apart
today. I first started thinking about this
when I went to Sweden to give a talk about
10 years ago on U.S., China human rights issues.
And I had a whole talk prepared about the
contrasts between our particular focus on
some rights, and the UN's universal human
rights package, like religious freedom loom
very large for us. In China at that time,
social and economic rights looms very large,
and I was going to talk how these fit in to
our histories and traditions. But I was interviewed
by a Swedish student radio station. And they
said, so when you talk about U.S.-China human
rights, you're going to talk about the human
rights issue that we in Sweden often think
of China and the U.S. being in the same category.
I said I don't know, what exactly do you have
in mind. Well, you both have legalized executions.
So the death penalty was thought of there
as having--. This was just something that
was eye opening, as a lot of times when you
have discussions outside of China and the
U.S. and you see that we are thought of as
two continent-sized countries that have always
talked about how much we hate imperialism.
That seem to have managed to have, over time,
extend our territorial control. There is a
lot of ways in which we are put in the same
category. But what I talk about more in the
book, is how China today has a lot in common
with the United States, at the period when
we were a rapidly industrializing, rapidly
urbanizing, rising economic power, that was
being seen as a really challenge to the previous
existing powers. So the United States from
the 1870s to the 1930s. Prior to that the
empires, the British Empire and the French
Empire these were the major powers in the
world. London and Paris were the leading cities
in the world. The United States cities were
rising up and one of the ways they were rising
up and challenging those cities place in the
world was by hosting world's fairs. The descendents
of which are World's Expo, Shanghai is just
hosting one.
Our railways were impressing the world, much
like the railways of China are now. So one
of the last questions I bring up is what kinds
of things do China and the United States have
in common. What other things. This comes after
the comment on Sweden. There are many other
parallels, some of which concern precisely
the things that Americans are fond of criticizing
about the PRC. For example, as Peter Hessler,
one of my favorite writers on China has noted
in an article about the instant cities of
China, where many factories use machines which
are pirated versions of U.S. ones. The United
States' industrial take-off was fueled in
part by just this sort of reverse engineering
that allowed businessmen in early U.S. boom
towns to make use, for free, of patented British
technologies. And as the US historian Stephen
Mihm has pointed out, in the late 1800's,
it was the United States, that was often seen
by Europeans as China is often seen now by
Americans. As a place that produced inferior
and sometimes downright dangerous goods, and
issues pirated editions of best sellers. Dickens
complained bitterly about how many unauthorized
versions of his books were sold across the
Atlantic when he came here. Something else
the countries have in common is that between
the late 1800s and mid 1900s the United States
built railways and highway systems on a grand
scale, which connected parts of the country
that were previously cut off from one another
and were sometimes hailed as engineering marvels.
That was also the era when the United States
hosted its first World's Fairs and it's first
Olympics. And as Susan Brownell, sports anthropologist
reminds us, when the United States first got
to hold the games in 1904, and previously
the event had only been held in Europe, some
foreign commentators assumed as they did again
during the lead up to 2008 that the IOC had
made a terrible mistake in letting the Olympics
be hosted by a country that might have a booming
economy but was clearly not ready for prime
time. And I have a few slides of the coming
of the Expo, and the excitement, the generation
and destruction and construction on a massive
scale that's going on for it. And I'd been
taking these, most of them I've taken, but
some of them are from others, but this was
us, a plan for it, it isn't exactly the same,
but you see the different nations of the world
being represented by different pavilions.
And then I recently went to Philadelphia to
look at the sole remaining major building
from the Philadelphia World's Fair Memorial
Hall, that's been turned into in part a museum
about, a children's museum, but it also has
displays about the history of World's Fairs,
and you see the same kind of layout of, nations
of the world being represented there in 1876.
And one of the things to note is the kind
of cockiness of the United States then and
China now, this world's fair wasn't just the
first one, the Philadelphia wasn't just the
first one held outside of Europe, it was the
biggest ever held. Shanghai's Expo isn't just
the first Expo held in China, it's the biggest
ever held. There's also that kind of thing.
Trains were an important symbol at the Philadelphia
World's Fair, people could get there with
amazing speed, thanks to the new railways
and from wide distances. One symbol in Shanghai
of it's readiness to host the World's Fair
was the Maglev super fast train being put
on display there before the World's Fair.
This is also just describing this being a
time when the United States was bragging about
its ability to extend its reach further across
the nation. And there's an image I end with
here, which I've used in talks ever since
I took the picture several years ago but it
has different meanings at different times.
I first did it simply, just to display the
fact that in Shanghai there was a big Hype,
World's Fairs have always been hyped. Chinese
are not new at doing this thing, it's going
to be the biggest and best ever. The U.S.
said the same thing for theirs. But lately,
as American fears about China have been growing
and a lot of American concern, in part because
of the hacking issue and in part because of
the economic issues, and part because of all
sorts of things I've noticed there's this
nervousness in America about China's arrival,
China being the new potential power, much
like there's a nervousness though, there's
an added thing to it now because of China's,
thinking of China being so radically different.
Whereas when Europeans saw America rise, there
was a fear but there was also some sense of
cultural similarity. But this picture started
to take on a new meaning and it actually I
can see through a certain American eyes, the
size of this giant baby coming towards you
might be a little creepy. At this point in
my talk, you know I'm an academic and I've
tried to do this in a fairly light accessible
way, I've brought in the John Denver thing,
this is, you know how pop has this guy gone?
So I like to end by showing, I'll read one
final bit from the book, before that when
I show this picture now, I like to reattach
with my academic side, and this makes me think
of a quote by Homer...Simpson.
[Audience laughter]
He said, "Children are our future, unless
we stop them now." And I think the American
attitude toward China has gone from saying
there's like sort of, if only they could learn
from us, and they could become more like us,
and they could grow to be kind of this adult
nation among nations, that would be great.
To now worrying about what's gonna happen
to us once they are this full-fledged power.
But I need to end with the last question in
the book. So I think this is important especially
after I talk about similarities. Is talking
about similarities between China and the U.S.,
does this, is this an argument for Americans
to refrain from all criticism of China, and
I say No. I want to emphasize this. Increased
awareness of similarities such as those just
noted need not prevent or even discourage
Americans from criticizing things that occur
in China. And when I get a chance to be interviewed
on radio I'll try to, whatever the topic is,
to slip in something about something that
concerns me in China like the sentencing of
Liu Xiaobo for an internet petition to 11
years in prison, which I think is something
we should criticize. But while acknowledging
similarities shouldn't stop us from criticizing
things that occur in China, or necessarily
stop Chinese from criticizing things in America.
It could change how we go about doing this.
It suggests that, as Stephen Mihm, the American
extraordinaire, I quoted before puts it, "if
we want to understand how to deal with China
we could do worse than look at our own history
as a guide." And he says when Americans take
the PRC to task for certain things, "a bit
of empathy might even be in order." If the
residents of each super power thought as much
about how much they have in common as what
makes them different it could even help increase
the odds that whichever way criticisms fly
across the Pacific, they will be delivered
in a less arrogant and patronizing fashion
than has sometimes been the case in the past.
Another thing that could help ease U.S.-China
misunderstandings would simply be for people
in each country to know more about the people
living in the other. I hope that U.S. readers
who have made it to the end of this book feel
that they now know a few more things about
the people of the PRC than they did when they
read its first pages. And I look forward to
the day when I can point my Chinese friends
toward a comparable work that tries to tell
them in a similar spirit of seeking to normalize
the experiences of a large and exotic seeming
anti-imperialist empire that stands by the
Pacific, everything they need to know about
the United States. Thanks for your attention.
[audience applause]
Jeff: And I'm happy to take any questions,
comments, criticisms, any subject.
male #4: Thanks very much. That was a great
introduction.
Jeff: Thanks.
male #4: I can't help thinking, sort of, what
is going to happen to things like Hong Kong,
which as you said is so different? What is
going to happen to Taiwan? And then if you
have some more thoughts, what is going to
happen in the Chinese countryside which is,
they're all so different from the part of
China that you've been focusing on.
Jeff: Yeah. That's a great question. Um, and
in a way I think, I mean they're inter-related
in differing ways. Certainly during the lead
up to the handover of Hong Kong in 1997 there
were a lot of predictions including one that
I made that expected much quicker, tighter
controls to come in, sort of, of media for
example. I try not to make specific predictions
about the future even though I'm writing about
the present. But I did go on record making
one prediction before 1997, before July 1st,
I said that, I'd been in Hong Kong to talk
about a film about the Tiananmen protests,
at a Hong Kong University, and the students
in the audience, it had been a very moving
thing because the students were sort of saying
will we have to face this kind of brutality
next year? And I said I'm not gonna make any
predictions about Hong Kong's future except
I will predict that after July 1st this film
won't be able to be shown here. After July
1st it was shown for a month in a local theatre,
in part because the government was trying
to convince investors not to pull out their
money, in part because there were a lot of
Chinese officials who wanted to see the film,
and Hong Kong becomes a place that you can
go to get a sense of how China's being discussed
in ways that aren't allowed to be discussed
in the country. So the predictions of Hong
Kong being totally swallowed up and becoming
kind of a controlled thing have not materialized,
in part though because the Hong Kong people
have stood up quite bravely to moments when
it seemed like tighter control was being brought.
Hong Kong is very related to what's the future,
possible future of Taiwan, because one reason,
along with investment that the Chinese government
has at some times pulled its punches with
Hong Kong, is it wants to convince people
in Taiwan over the long term that there could
be a way in which they would be integrated
into the territory of China, the state of
China while still maintaining the ability
to live very differently which is what Hong
Kong is then, the potential model for that.
Um, but the future of it, I mean how long
this can continue with the, but I think there's,
at the moment there's a value to China, to
Beijing, to have Hong Kong operate separately
in a variety of ways. Certainly they rely
on a lot of the boom in Shanghai as largely
been investment. Sometimes called foreign
investment, but foreign direct-investment,
but sometimes coming from Hong Kong, which
is part of China, but it's still, you have
to get a separate, it's almost treated like
crossing a border, an international border
when you go there. So it's a very anomalous,
unusual situation that's lasted longer than
a lot of us expected. The Chinese countryside,
the changes there have been just enormous.
And I think the question for the future is
in part that a lot of the, a lot of rural
areas have been left behind by the economic
booms and they've gotten some benefits from
it in part by workers from the countryside
going to the cities, working to, the workers
of this economic boom have largely been migrant
workers going to factory towns and sending
their money back to the countryside. Uh, one
thing that's happened I think, the most important,
two of the most important things to keep in
mind, one is the Chinese government has set
itself up in promising that over the long
run life will get significantly better materially
for all Chinese, but that some people will
get rich first. So there are people who haven't
benefited as much from the economic reforms,
have maybe gotten just some small bits of
improvement who are thinking their turn will
come eventually. This has made the Chinese
government addicted to growth, high growth
rates. If economic growth, slowed, tapered
off, or came to a stop, you'd have a lot of
very angry people, who are already maybe angry
at, are angry at corruption and the unevenness
of the spread of wealth, of new wealth. But
then would be furious. Because it wouldn't
be that they were waiting their turn, it would
be that their turn would never come. So that's
I think something that concerns the Chinese
government a great deal. It's why they've
begun to try to move toward meliorating the
growing difference between rural and urban
prosperity.
The second thing though to think about, and
this is true for rural and urban Chinese and
I haven't talked about enough is just the
wide spread degradation of the environment
which is I think the single biggest issue
that we should all be worried about relating
to China. I think there are problems with
having too much fear about China owning so
much American debt which is something that
Americans often focus on. It's an issue of
concern but the Chinese and American economies
are really intertwined. The Chinese government
depends a lot on us buying goods made in China.
And the Chinese government is more dependent
than we are on continued economic growth,
because if there's an economic crisis in China,
it won't just be like the economic crisis
in the United States where a lot of people
complain but very few people take to the streets.
In China there will be much more serious consequences,
so I think some of the economic worries are
overblown, but I think the worry about, simply
the fact that the impossibility of the worlds
being able to take the environmental impact
of China and then potentially other places,
developing very environmentally, degrading
lifestyles, which of course were partly inspired
by emulation of us. So it's a complicated
moral issue, but it's simply the major issue
out there in the country side. It's a big
issue, as well as in the city. Did I get part
of it? Ok. Good.
male #5: Thanks again for coming. Um, my questions
on the valuation of currency. Ah it's been
a really hot button issue and it's, I think
become kind of a proxy for so many of the
points that you've touched on today. So, I
guess I'm wondering what are your impressions
on how this back and forth is harkening to
potential future U.S.-China relations, and
do you think we'll see a revaluation in the
RMB any time soon?
Jeff: Um, predictive question. And I'm going
to a seminar in a couple of weeks. Just because
I wrote a book saying it's everything you'd
need to know about China, doesn't mean I don't
think I keep needing to learn. And I'm hoping
to learn things about the Internet in China
story in conversations here. Ah, this isn't
an area which is my main expertise, but I
think you've put your finger on it very well
about it being a kind of proxy for other concerns.
And I think this is yet another way in which,
sometimes China and the US are seen in a similar
way by some other parts of the world as countries
that like to do things in their own way and
at their own pace. I think one of the things
to expect is certainly that any revaluation
will come slowly and gradually because the
Chinese government, along with being concerned
about its international reputation, along
with being concerned about the economy, is
very concerned with just stability at all
costs. So nothing that will, that nothing
that will move things quickly is likely. I
think it's, I think it's likely to remain
a thorny issue, and there're a bunch of thorny
issues between China and the U.S. So I think
in general the challenge is to figure out
there is no option between the two countries,
working together on a lot of things, and so
that, we can expect it to be a time, we can
expect to see a lot of small tensions clearly
between the two countries as they're adjusting
to different places in the world. And this
is gonna be one of the things that I think
is gonna keep being a source of tension, in
part because of our desire for things, for
quick solutions and the Chinese government
likely to want to go very slow at all costs.
Thanks for that question.
male #6: When we're talking about Hong Kong,
we're usually asking what the people of Hong
Kong think. I'm wondering what the perception
is from the mainland urban Chinese about Hong
Kong. Do they understand the special deal
that Hong Kong citizens have? And also particularly
in the context of Google Search having moved
to be served from Hong Kong, what is the perception
of that for people in Beijing and Shanghai?
Do they look at it as no longer Chinese?
Jeff: That's' a very good question. And there
are a couple of parts to the answer. One is
that I think if you moved to Google Shanghai
you'd have a certain number of Chinese saying
that's, you know, there's a saying that, "Shanghai
isn't really China". And I think it's been
harder to get a complete backing for the Expo
because while in some cases, it's seen as
Shanghai isn't seen that always as representing
the country. There's a lot of Anti-Shanghainese
sentiment which I'm quite comfortable with
having grown up in L.A. and knowing how the
rest of the country views California
Ok, so there you have it. So that's one part
of the question. Another part I would say
is that when I lived in Shanghai in the mid
1980s and I told some of my friends that I
was going to be going to Hong Kong for some
R and R and a break from Shang' they were
like you know, when you come back you've gotta
tell us what that, you know, is it really
as different and special as we always, as
we hear about, and you know, what are the
stores like, what are the roads like? And
when I, and it was dramatic then to go from
Shanghai to Hong Kong, it was utter culture
shock, much more from going from, yeah from
Shanghai to another part of China. But now
if I'm going to Shanghai and I tell people
I'm going to Hong Kong in a day or two, they
just shrug like you know, so what? We can,
you know, we can do all those things that
we want to and people go from Hong Kong to
Shanghai to have fun, which was unthinkable
in the mid 80's which I can't convey to you
how boring it was to live in Shanghai in those
days. I mean it's fascinating but in terms
of entertainment, in terms of options of things
to do it just didn't hold a candle to Hong
Kong and now it does, so that's another thing.
I mean the view of Hong Kong while it's viewed
as different I mean now I would say it also
is that there, you know people outside of,
I mean it would be a really good question
to ask people to categorize because I think
in some ways people in say a rustbelt city
of the North East, that is declining, they
might think of Shanghai and Hong Kong and
Shenzhen and to some extent even Beijing as
you know having a radically different kind
of life to what they have. So I think in terms
of the, so there are a lot of things with
that. So it plays into a kind of notion that
the leads are more the places that have prospered
vs. those that haven't as well as the differentiation
of setting. But I think there's also a lot
of, there's also a lot of curiosity, there's
not a lot of absolute understanding of again
it would be people who have moved between
those places, people who've spent time in
Hong Kong, you know, may realize, they may
see a kind of fit. Well sure, because in Hong
Kong they know that the bookstores are totally
different so they'd understand why something
else related to media, they know that the
newspapers are very different there. To others,
so I think there'd be a lot of range of variation
on that. But I do think it's important to
realize how foreign to some extent some of
the cities within the mainland are even if
when we focus on control of information there's
a world of difference between a Shanghai bookstore
and a Hong Kong bookstore that people are
focusing on other things may be putting these
much richer and more developed and more linked
to the West places in one category. Thanks
female #3: You've mentioned the internet a
couple of times, and I just thought it'd be
interesting to hear, you know with your background
a little bit more about your reaction of some
of the events between Google and China's government.
Jeff: Yeah, Yeah. Well I'd love to learn more
about that because, um, it's a story I've
certainly been following very closely, but
I think there, it's been, and I can tell you
who I read that I think is particularly good
on following this; I read Rebecca McKinnon
who blogs about the Internet in China and
is working on a book about the Internet and
I think will be really important. There's
a guy named Yang Guobin who wrote a book called
"The power of the Internet in China," who
has a more upbeat, in some ways, view of the
possibility of the Internet for civil society
and new things going on. Um, I guess one of
my takes is that to me at least the Google
in China story is probably more significant
as a business story than an information story
because in part, I mean for a variety of reasons,
some of which I've mentioned, the fact that
for some people they go, they'll, some people
were never using Google in the first place
to cruise the net, were not interested, thought
Baidu did everything they needed, why bother.
And maybe even had some preference for an
indigenous based company anyway. Some were
going through VPN's and now if they were using
Google will still be using Google and so forth.
But I think it's a tremendously significant
business story and I think that's a reason
to watch it because it is an effort to alter
the playing field in the kinds of negotiations
that go on between China and foreign countries.
And as somebody, ah Zachary Karabell who wrote
a book "Superfusion", he was on a panel with
me and he said, you know you have to take
into account what a company can do if it's
not making giant profits or not centrally
concerned for its profits, so his line was
to borrow it with attribution, was Google
can stay or leave with China. Dell computers,
it's not an option. So I think you know, that
is important to keep in mind that they're
both moral decisions. The other thing that's
been striking to me is how quickly the story
that I think a lot of Americans that just
have a casual following of China, might think
that the decision is all about censorship,
whereas the, you know, the spur was largely
about security and hacking. So I think that's,
that would be the crucial thing, I think,
to bring back into the picture to disentangle
those two things which are, I think quite
different.
[audience applauding]